the white house stirring up outrage over
the supply chain crisis as some ceos say
president biden waited way too long to
fix the nation's broken system and that
christmas is coming very soon the
president's chief of staff ron klain
again sparking backlash after promoting
a tweet playing down the inflation
supply chain concerns millions of
americans have referring to them as
high-class problems here's the quote
most of the economic problems we're
facing are high-class problems we
wouldn't have had them if the
unemployment rate was still 10
we would have instead have had a much
worse problem okay fine but the white
house defending the tweet saying this
why would ron plane tweet that and would
you agree that's a little bit toned down
do you think two tweets means more i'm
just curious we're at this point because
the unemployment rate has come down and
been cut in half
because
because people are buying more goods
because people are traveling and because
demand is up and because the economy is
turning back on are we addressing the
chief of staff's twitter habits
it is not a top priority uh i would tell
you at this point in time uh
the chief of staff is out there speaking
on his own accord to members of congress
to the media
frequently
as any chief of staff does and i think
it's important also for anyone here to
be able to
tout
points that they find interesting all
this is americans brace for a spike in
their gas bills this winter take a look
at this chart axios put together
forecasting what increases in fuel
prices for average households are going
to look like the cost of propane and
heating oil are shooting up like a
rocket and that is going to take hold
very soon i have so many thoughts
so many thoughts okay you remember uh
jesse retweet doesn't equal endorsement
yeah however ron klain is not tweeting
in his personal capacity he's always
tweeting and retweeting like a teenage
girl retweeting and retweeting all these
things and he didn't just retweet it he
said this in all caps and with two
arrows down saying this is what they
think i think this is like their
deplorables moment i don't think it's
going to end like a teenage girl dana
sorry i'm in a mood today you're better
than that i just want to apologize to
the audience
teenage girls aren't even on twitter so
that wasn't very very good to apologize
on tick tock
[Laughter]
yeah so clean's not a great chief of
staff that's clear uh and sake bombed
today all she had to say was we're on it
we're gonna do whatever we can to
release pressure on these prices but she
says that inflation is a sign of
progress that is a really bad answer to
people that are getting hammered they've
been all over the map on trying to
answer questions first they said there
is no inflation then they said it's
transitory and now they're saying oh
it's a sign of progress it's just not
it's just not going to cut it and it
doesn't affect wealthy people barely at
all you can't fly you can't buy you
can't hire life has not been made easier
by joe biden's presidency and this is
where we are now i watched the whole
press briefing because i wanted to see
how she'd answer and the media is on the
side of the democrats but they're not
doing the democrats any favors when half
of their questions are about trump
half of their questions are about the
january 6
subpoena battle you go outside and talk
to people on the streets no one knows
what that is no one cares half the
people don't know what the word subpoena
is so if they think that the country
cares about that they're not informed
about what the country cares about yes
sometimes fox acts about the border
supply chains inflation crime that's it
but they're not being well served by the
mainstream media who makes everything to
be about trump if you even he gets a win
let's say he gets a win a smaller win on
some of these spending deals you still
are not going to feel the impact of that
for years you know how long it takes to
build a plug-in for an electric car or
how long it takes to get a new
government program off the ground all
you're going to see immediately are tax
hikes so he's coming into a winter you
could see more covid in the northern
united states you're going to obviously
see high home eating bills more fuel
prices through the roof it's going to be
tough data heating oil is going to be up
53
that's from the government that's what
they said um the other thing it's a sign
of prosperity yeah oh yeah don't don't
you realize yes and it's great if you
keep the temperature down that's really
good for your metabolism oh so you can
lose weight too yeah thank you what's a
low-class problem
like when this is a high class problem
what's is a low class problem hunter
biden like you know
cocaine and hookers i'm really confused
i i realize that a high-class problem is
a problem that only the high classes can
weather right right so you know this is
exactly the same tactic they dealt with
crime and immigration it doesn't affect
us therefore it doesn't exist there will
be no toy shortages for pelosi's
grandkids or jeff suckers offspring or
any jerk and legacy media they're
they're fine that's why they don't care
about this crap i also love how joe
biden is asking the oil industry for
help
this is the industry he hurt just as he
got into office he could just reverse
all the actions he took against them
rather than asking for help that brought
us to this place he's like a guy that
asked to sleep at your house after he
burns it down he i mean it's a
legitimate question given his faculties
maybe he doesn't remember that he was
the guy that killed the pipeline old
yeah but i mean he might have forgotten
that he killed the pipeline or shut down
frank fracking on federal lands or
stopped new leasing he might have
forgotten that he demonized i'm trying
to be helpful here that maybe it's not
his fault but now he's saying to the
people he screwed hey i could use a hand
here could you help me put out this fire
i started going back to yesterday you
guys got to pick up the slack yeah
because i screwed up you guys now have
to pick up the slack here's a ceo who
responded to that today to the
suggestion that the private sector needs
to step up
see well with all due respect to
president biden
what he just ordered is too little too
late it's only 72 days left to christmas
and whether the ports are open 24 hours
a day
or 48 hours a day you cannot get labor
if you cannot get labor you cannot get
trucks you cannot get those merchandise
out and even if you get them out it's
going to be too late for christmas
geraldo the private sector was saying we
want to sell product we want to move
product we would do it if we could the
problem is there are these bottlenecks
and not enough truck drivers well i i
guess that is a problem of course and
you go back to why we need more uh young
truck drivers out there working but the
problem with what clayne
uh retweeted is that it has a marie
antoinette vibe to it it's a let them
eat cake kind of vibe uh and it it's a
it's a those lower classes they've got
their issues and we
upper and that's always why i i hated
the ivy league harvard
uh oriented uh democratic party the
elite of the party uh
but the reason it's all happening is
covet is still the atmospheric it's
bumming everybody out it's separating
everybody basketball players and and uh
you know
black people and cops and this and so
you have covet and then you have the the
the residual
lingering wound from afghanistan we we
never got over that's what pierce the
the the shield of joe biden once he was
shown to be vulnerable there i remember
sitting here and
surprising myself by my uh my
my criticism of president biden's
chaotic evacuation and as i was speaking
i said wow i'm really nailing him and i
like him and if i'm doing that then you
know it's a there's a trickle-down
effect and i really think it's bad uh
but there's a lot of other things that
are worse one of the things that
happened today so there's these guys at
the it's called liberal patriot they are
moderate conservatives and they have a
free sub stack so you could check it out
but just this morning before all of this
ron claim tweet thing happened they had
a piece that said the democratic party
has a huge problem they are not doing
anything to win back the working class
and then a tweet like this is why i
would imagine that even though she had
to defend it today at the press briefing
room if she could take twitter away from
the white house officials i think she
probably would as dana always says you
don't have to tweet everything and you
twitter gets you in trouble so it's
better not to say more
it's better to say less and more don't
tweet but look this administration since
the beginning has a pattern they take a
policy position that involves attacking
an industry so they attack oil and gas
they attack uh private businesses with
regulations they throw in a vaccine
mandate to distract from afghanistan
without actually issuing a rule and then
they say then they pump the economy full
of all this money so that employers have
to compete with the federal government
so there aren't enough workers to get
goods to service and then when things
don't work out and there's a crisis as a
result of all these policy positions
instead of changing the policy or
pivoting they attack the industry and
say you have to bail us out you have to
fix this now it's one thing for
christmas presents not to get delivered
on time which can we call joe biden
scrooge or the grinch yet but it's
another thing when basic goods can't get
delivered on time and this
administration tends to bury its head
and say there's nothing happening
there's no crisis here this was
inevitable but they better get ready
because there will be civil unrest if
they don't prepare for things to get
delivered like milk and food diapers
grocery stores diapers basic things
people are going to be fighting over
less amount of television
that's going to get ugly they fight
every year worse than that
together i'm telling you right coming up
the media is souring on president biden
why one prominent liberal says the
honeymoon is over hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else